MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BEING
P. PROFESSIONS HEARING COMMITTEE
COUPLE OF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS THE
FOLLOWING BILL HAS BEEN PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR SB ONE NINETY
THREE BY SENATOR NIELSEN.
AND WE ALSO HAVE ONE BILL ON THE
CONSENT WHICH IS SB.
THREE NINETY ONE A BY SENATOR
MINING -- SO WE WILL -- BEGIN AS
A SUB COMMITTEE BUT NOW ARE
WAITING CURRENTLY.
FOR OUR AUTHORS SO WE'LL POSIT
JUST WAIT AS THE SERGEANTS ARE
CALLING. TO HAVE OUR AUTHORS
JOIN US IN PRISON
OKAY WELL WHAT WE WILL BEGIN
THEN I HAVE AS WE ARE.
PRESENTS WITH AN AUTHOR WHO
BEGIN.
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR CABALLERO.
AND AGAIN MEMBERS WERE ACTING AS
A SUB COMMITTEE AND WE'LL WAIT.
FOR A QUORUM BUT UNTIL THEN WE
WILL MOVE ON WITH.
ANY BUSINESS. TO COVER WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AT PLEASURE TO BE BACK
IN THE ASSEMBLY -- FIRST LET ME
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE
STARTING ON JANUARY FIRST TWO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO POST ON THEIR
INTERNET WEBSITE OR R. OR ON
THAT CALIFORNIA CANNABIS PORTAL
CERTAIN INFORMATION ABOUT AN
APPLICANT IN LICENSEE WHICH IS
PUBLIC INFORMATION.
UNDER THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
THE BILL WILL BRING TRANSPARENCY
TO THE NEW THIS NEWLY LEGALIZED
INDUSTRY AND PROVIDE THE PUBLIC
AND INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS WITH
THE CENTRALIZED LIST OF WHO IS
APPLYING FOR THE CANNABIS
LICENSES.
AND WHO IS LICENSED IN THE STATE.
THE BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION THAT COULD
NOT BE ATTAINED THROUGH A PUBLIC
RECORDS REQUEST AND IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE AVERAGE CITIZEN MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND HOW TO RECEIVE.
THIS INFORMATION THROUGH A
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST.
WE KNOW LICENSING AUTHORITIES
CURRENTLY PROVIDE SIMILAR
INFORMATION AS REQUIRED IN SB.
FIVE EIGHTY ONE FOR OTHER
INDUSTRIES ULTIMATELY CALIFORNIA
NEEDS POLICIES TO CREATE A
TRANSPARENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
THIS CITIZENS WORKERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS CAN EASILY ACCESS
FOR THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS UNDER
DOCTOR RECALL WITH THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
AND I BELIEVE RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF KHALIFA [inaudible]
SEVEN THE MORNING SHOW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I TO I'M HAPPY
TO BE BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY A
BIRD OF CURRICULA -- REPRESENT
THE UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNSEL.
AND SUPPORTING SPONSOR OF THE
LEGISLATION -- WE'RE WORKING
WITH SENATOR COUPLE YEAR ON THIS
MEASURE.
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES --
GETTING THE INFORMATION
REGARDING APPLICANTS AND IN FACT
LICENSEES.
FROM THE FROM THE RESPECTIVE
AGENCIES THAT ARE ARE CHARGED
WITH ISSUING THE LIVES AND
OVERSEEING THESE THIS INDUSTRY.
THIS IS NOT MEANT AS A CRITICISM
IT'S JUST SOME OF STATEMENT OF
FACT.
IT'S A NEW INDUSTRY -- THE
RESOURCES AREN'T AVAILABLE YET
TO THE AGENCIES HOWEVER -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS SORT OF A
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP WHERE
THAT IF THE INFORMATION IS
POSTED ONLINE IN REAL TIME -- WE
CAN WE CAN ASSIST IN AND FLAG.
CONCERNS FLAG ISSUES -- WE'RE
ALSO THE OTHER CHALLENGE OVER WE
HAVE WE HAVE FACED IS TO THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST.
RECEIVING DIFFERENT INFORMATION.
FOR THE SAME REQUEST EVEN FROM
THE SAME AGENCY SO WE WOULD YOU
WANT TO GET SOME KIND OF
CONSISTENCY FOR THE
INFORMATION'S COMING I WANT TO
BE IN REAL TIME AND WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ASSIST AGENCIES.
IN VETTING THESE APPLICANTS ALL
WEIRD AS THE AUTHOR IS COMING
AND I KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THIS.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE SOCIAL
EQUITY PART OF OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS ALONG THE WAY. TO
ASSURE THAT PREVIOUS CONVICTIONS
ARE AND THEN ARE IN NO WAY HELD
AGAINST APPLICANTS -- THE
AMENDMENT -- THE WE'RE TAKING
TODAY IT HAS TO DO WITH CAN WITH --
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY POST LICENSURE
WHICH WE THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
AS AN AS AN IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURES.
BUT THAT -- DEPRECIATE TO
SUPPORT OF THE THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LEVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS RAM MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF COOLEY EVEN SAN JOSE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
G. V. HAIRS ON BEHALF OF JASON
BRYANT -- REPRESENTING THE
HUMBLE GRANT COUNTY GROWERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE NOW WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION FEEL FREE TO PLEASE
COME UP TO THE TABLE HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR THE
AMENDMENTS WE FEEL THAT -- IT'S
A MUCH IMPROVED BILL WITH THAT
THE CHANGES AND SO WE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE.
WE ARE STILL IN OPPOSITION --
CCA DOES SUPPORT A TRANSPARENT
RESPONSIBLE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
AND DOES APPLY THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSORS INTENT TO STRENGTHEN
PUBLIC TRUST AND LICENSE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
HOWEVER WE DO BELIEVE THERE ARE
STILL SOME ELEMENTS OF THE BILL
THAT ARE PROBLEMATIC CRITICALLY
AROUND A PREVIOUS ACCUSATIONS
RELATIVE TO LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS -- CITATIONS AND
FINES ISSUED WHICH ARE
CORRECTABLE OFFENSES AND
ACCUSATIONS TO THE AG WITHOUT
DUE PROCESS SO WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR WILL
BE TAKING TODAY -- TWO EST ROUTE
TO ASSESS THAT POSITION BUT AT
THIS TIME WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
NAME AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO.
AMBER MORRIS OF NOR CAL CANNABIS
I WANTED TO NOTE THAT WERE ON
THE ANALYSIS IS BOTH IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WE HAVE NOT BEEN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SO.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
MELANIE CUEVAS WITH KING TUNNEL
IT'S AND HEART AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION.
WE'LL LINE OUR OPPOSITION
WITHOUT OF THE CIA AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DON'T REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME AND
WE FEEL THAT THE CURRENT HERE I
REQUEST.
AND IS SUFFICIENT TO COVER BOTH
THE NEEDS OF PRIVACY AND
BOUNCING TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE NOW ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CAMINO.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CONSUMERS AT THIS TIME
SENATOR CAREER DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND
WE WILL TAKE OF THE MEASURE WHEN
WITH THE STEPS TO QUORUM FORGET
THANK YOU.
SENATE COVER.
MEMBERS WOULD JUST.
WAIT FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS AND
WE'RE JUST SHORT ONE MEMBER TO
STEPS A QUORUM.
SO WE'LL WAIT PATIENTLY AND WHEN
THE SENATORS ARRIVE.
I HAVE A
YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY
THE
OKAY LET'S ESTABLISH A CORE.
WELL HERE BRO BLOOM.
ARAMBULA.
CHEN.
JILL CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN FONG GIPSON GLORIA
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE
TING.
OKAY WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM SO.
LET'S MOVE IN.
MORTAR OF BUSINESS WHICH IS
CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB.
THREE NINETY ONE KATE MOTION AND
A SECOND.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB THREE
NINETY ONE MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
LOW I THROW ARAMBULA REPEAL AYE
BLOOM.
CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
I AM I EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GLORIA
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING?
TENNIS ZERO WORLD WITH THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE BY CENTER
COMPARE THERE'S A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION PLEASE.
MR MEDINA MOTIONS AND THE TO
FONG SECONDS THREE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI SO I BROKE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN OFFERING CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING I'M NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
AND I HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA.
MEDIA HI MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE TING [inaudible]
EGGMAN. SIX ZERO RELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS --
AND TO I KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CALLING FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS.
MEMBERS WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING IN FIVE
MINUTES IF WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
SENATORS THAT WILL BE PRESENTING
AS WE HAVE BE.
GAINED THE COMMITTEE HEARING AT
NINE THIRTY AND IT IS NOW.
955- SO DIGITAL FIVE MINUTES AND
WE WILL CLOSE THIS HEARING
SEN
COUNTER SB THREE NINETY ONE
MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
BLOOM BUT MY SB FIVE ANYONE MUCH
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE
FIRST RARE GOING TO
NOW ALLOW FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN WHO IS A DISTINGUISHED
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
SKINNER.
GIVEN THAT THERE IS AN I
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
THAT ALSO THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB FOUR SEVEN FIVE
BY SENATORS.
SKINNER.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS THAT WE ARE ALL
WELL VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
CANNABIS MARKET IS JUST ALLOWS
FOR SMALL SAMPLES TO BE.
SHARED BETWEEN AT DEALER SO THAT
THEY CAN THEN.
IN ORDER OF THEIR GOING TO
PURCHASE A QUANTITY OR NOT IS A
STANDARD AND ALL OTHER MARKETS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL THAT HAS PORTS PORT
AND NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT -- WE THINK THIS
WILL CREATE A MORE COST
EFFECTIVE METHOD FOR PROVIDING
CANNABIS -- GIVE MORE -- ACTS TO
GET BETTER ACCESS TO NEW
OPERATORS SO THEY CAN GET TO
MARKET WITH THEIR PRODUCTS --
AND GIVEN THE SUPPORT -- FOR THE
BILL WE AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAN MEMBERS
MAXIMA CLOSE ON BEHALF OF FLOW
CON -- CANNABIS SON GROWN
PROSSER DISTRIBUTOR ON NORTH
COAST WE'RE PLEASED TO CO
SPONSORS BEFORE SEVENTY FIVE FOR
PROFESSIONAL LIVES TO BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS TRADE SAMPLES
PROCESS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT IS YOU KNOW WHEN THIS IS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
INFORMATION IF YOU WERE TO TURN
MEMBERS RANDOM ARE NOT BE HAVE A
BLACK BIRD LOGISTICS AND SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN NOR WOULD
ON BEHALF OF CAMPUS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
AMBER MORRIS WITH NOR CAL
CANNABIS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE CUEVAS ON
BEHALF OF CCMA THE CALIFORNIA
CAMPUS MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION
OFTEN SUPPORT.
BREMER FEUD WITH MAPS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO MEMBERS SPEAKING QUESTION
SPEAKING OPPOSITION THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FOR SEVENTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW
AYE BRO ARAMBULA.
I BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM?
CAN I AM I EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG?
PHONE UP VOTING.
GIPSON.
GLORIA FOR AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN.
I MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE REALTY I TING. TWELVE
VOTES THAT BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW DO.
WAITING FOR TO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
FIVE ONE FORTY TWO CENTER WIENER
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA A CALL
THROUGH CONSENT ONCE AGAIN WHEN
A SECTOR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB THREE
NINETY ONE MOTIONS YOU PASTA
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
JUNE.
GIPSON GLORIA.
GORE AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY MULLIN TANK
[inaudible]
THE FOURTEEN ZERO BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
BUT THEN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS SB.
FIVE NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD WELCOME CENTER THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS AND THIS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT. FIVE NINETY FIVE WHICH
WILL ENABLE INDIVIDUALS FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S LEGALIZED AND
GROWING CANNABIS INDUSTRY
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE NINE FIVE
WILL HELP ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
CREATING EQUITABLE INDUSTRY.
BY REQUIRING THE STATE LICENSING
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FEE TO FOR ALL AND WAIVERS OF
FEES TO OBTAIN A RENEW A STATE
LICENSE FOR LOCAL.
EQUITY APPLICANTS AND I
LICENSEES CITIES SUCH AS OAKLAND
SAN FRANCISCO LA -- SO SAN DIEGO
AND NOW ALL LONG BEACH.
HAVE DEVELOPED -- EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND AND AS I SAID LONG
BEACH.
NOW WHICH FOCUS ON INCLUSION IN
SUPPORT OF OUR APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MOST COMMUNITIES I
SHOULD SAY THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
HARMED BY THE DECADES WAR ON
DRUGS.
LAST YEAR WITH THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED -- AS WE BUILD.
NINETY FOUR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OR BECAUSE SHE'D COAL.
CODE YOU.
CULTURE I'M SORRY -- FROM THE
MINORITY CANNABIS -- ASSOCIATION
AND RODNEY HOKUM FROM ATTORNEY
FOR DRUG LINES -- DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP
TO THREE MINUTES OF TESTIMONY IN
TOTAL FOR AS MUCH AS YOU WISH TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU UP TO A CHAIR AND NOW
CAN IN MEMBERS OF THE MINORITY
CAM IS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IS
THE FIRST NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR REGULATED CAMPUS
BUSINESS OPERATORS FROM.
MINORITY COMMUNITIES NCBA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB -- FIVE
NINETY FIVE OUR NATIONS ARE
INDUSTRIES MINORITY
ENTREPRENEURS CONTINUE TO
COMPETE ON A VERY UNLEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
THE HIGH COST OF STATE LICENSING
AND RENEWAL FEES CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL IMPEDIMENT THAT
THREATENS TO PREVENT MOST
MINORITY CAMPUS BUSINESSES FROM
GETTING BEYOND.
A BUSINESS PLAN AND LAUNCHING
LAWFUL OPERATIONS THAT CAN
COMPETE ON A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
WITH OTHER CANDIDATES BUSINESSES.
WHILE THESE FEES ARE TEAR THEY
ARE COLLECTED FROM PRE REVENUE
BUSINESS IS BASED ON EXPECTED
REVENUE USING IT QUICKLY CLIMB
INTO THE TENS AND EVEN HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. FOR
THESE REASONS NCBA FEELS THAT
MANDATING STATE LICENSING
AGENCIES TO CREATE AND IMPLEMENT
APPLICATION LICENSE FEE WAIVERS
AND DEFERRALS FOR QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES UNDER.
LOCAL SUCH LIKE WE LICENSES AS
NECESSARY AND WARRANTED -- SO I
ON BEHALF OF NCBA WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB.
NINE FIVE NINETY FIVE A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS RANI HOKUM I'M STAFF
ATTORNEY A DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
CAMPAIGN FOR THE LEGALIZATION OF
MEDICAL AND RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF
DECADES.
AND WE'RE PRETTY INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR I
WAS LEGALIZED CAMPUS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY I COME
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETY FIVE WHICH WOULD.
A FURTHER THE STATE'S GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE AN
EQUITABLE CANNABIS INDUSTRY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE UNBELIEVABLE
HOW WE GOT HERE -- QUITE AWHILE
AGO CANNABIS WAS ILLEGAL IN THE
STATE AND MANY BLACK AND LATINO
PEOPLE WERE ARRESTED CONVICTED
AND INCARCERATED A FOR CANDACE
Là VIOLATIONS I FAST FORWARD TO
TODAY AND WE HAVE THE PASSAGE OF
PROP SIXTY FOUR IN THE CREATION
OF A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY SO MANY BLACK AND
LATINO PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CUT OUT
OF THIS INDUSTRY LARGELY BECAUSE
CAPITAL JUST DOES NOT EXIST --
WE KNOW FROM A REPORT BY THE
MIND OR AT BY THE MEN OF
MARIJUANA DAILY -- MARIJUANA
BUSINESS DAILY I THAT FEWER THAN
20% OF PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY
ARE BLACK OR LATINO AND THIS IS
A SHAME THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN CERTAINLY DO SOMETHING
ABOUT WE KNOW THAT THE PASSAGE
OF SB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD
FURTHER THE PURPOSE IS AN
ATTENTIVE PROP.
SIXTY FOUR AND SO I STRONG I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAY
MANIPULATION AT THE MICROPHONE.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP AND SUPPORT.
AMBER MOORE A SNORKEL CANNABIS
AND SUPPORT.
RG ON BEHALF OF SEIU IN SUPPORT.
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION CANNOT CRAFT IN
SUPPORT.
JEZEBEL WITH UCW WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA MURPHY WITH WITH MAPS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME CENTER BRADFORD YOU
WISH TO CLOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ADAMS JR
MEMBERS THIS IS A FREE A STREET
FOR MEASURE AS YOU SEE WE'VE
DONE MANY MUCH WORK I SHOULD SEE
IN THIS SPACE WHETHER IT'S BEEN
THE UTILITY INDUSTRY WHETHER
WOULD NOW DOING IN INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
LOOKING FOR A EQUITY INCLUSION%
TO REPRESENT -- THE GREAT
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS
INDUSTRY THAT'S TWO YEARS AN
EXIT LESSON TWO YEARS IN
EXISTENCE AND IT'S 80% WHITE
MALE DOMINATED AND THIS IS
OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW THOSE.
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN CHALLENGED
FOR THE LAST FORTY YEARS OR MORE
DRUGS SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
BRADFORD I DO WANT TO ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE.
AN ECONOMY THAT THRIVES FOR ALL
THAT I CAN BE INVOLVED TO
REFLECT THIS DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE AS WELL AND THIS HAS
RECEIVED BY PART OF SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE AND I'M.
HOPING TO SEE THAT SAME TYPE OF
SPIRIT IN THE OTHER HOUSE HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY SO WITH THAT
DISTANCE ENJOYED TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE NINETY FIVE MOTIONS
DEPOSIT APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW I PRO. FOR AYE ARAMBULA
RUBIO AYE BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING I'M NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
I FONG.
FONG UPLOADING GIPSON.
GLORIA GORE I GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN --
WE'RE NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW TING. ELEVEN TO
ONE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR FINAL
OTHER THAN IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB ONE
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR WIENER
[inaudible]
SENATOR WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S
COULD BE BACK.
SO OUR FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN IN THE KEY
STEP FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
BILL WERE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
ARE COLLEAGUES -- SB -- ONE
FORTY TWO WILL ENSURE THAT --
NEW MOTHERS ARE ABLE TO POST
RETURN TO WORK AND CONTINUE --
TO BREAST FEED ARE RIGHT NOW FAR
TOO MANY WOMEN -- PARTICULARLY --
OF NEW MOTHERS WHO ARE -- LOWER
INCOME -- AND DO NOT HAVE SORT
OF FANCY JOBS WITH PRIVATE
OFFICES ARE FORCED TO CHOOSE DO
I RETURN TO WORK.
AND STOP BREAST FEEDING MY CHILD.
WHERE DO I CONTINUE TO BREAST
FEED MY CHILD AND DELAY
RETURNING TO WORK -- EITHER ONE
IS UNTENABLE WHETHER TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES
ABOUT FAMILY -- OR THE HEALTH OF
THE CHILD.
AND THIS IS A FALSE CHOICE SO
WHAT THE BILL DOES IS IT.
PROVIDES SOME VERY BASIC AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD REQUIREMENTS --
TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN ARE ABLE TO
EXPRESS MILK AT WORK -- THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO IN A
RESTROOM WHICH IS EXISTING LAW.
BY EVEN IF WE'RE NOT REQUIRING
THEM TO IN A RESTROOM SHOULD
NEVER HAVE TO DO -- WE ALSO
DON'T WANT -- WOMEN TO HAVE TO
GO AND EXPRESS GOLD IN A BROOM
CLOSET FOR EXAMPLE SO THE THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT THE EMPLOYER
PROVIDE A PRIVATE SPACE.
WE CAN BE A ROOM FOR EMPLOYERS
WERE ROOM DOESN'T WORK EITHER IS
NO ROOM YOU CAN HAVE A TEMPORARY
STRUCTURE IT'S VERY FLEXIBLE AND
HOW THAT IS LAID OUT.
WITH A TABLE WITH A CHAIR --
WITH AN OUTLET -- AND WITH
NEARBY ACCESS TO REFRIGERATION
AND RUNNING WATER -- THIS IS NOT
AN EXTREME -- REQUIREMENT -- I
THINK IT'S THE LEAST WE CAN DO --
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE -- BRINGING
FORTH THE NEXT GENERATION OF
HUMANKIND -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN -- BOTH WORK AND BREAST
FEED.
NOW WE KNOW THAT BREAST FEEDING
HAVE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH BENEFITS --
FOR FOR BABIES -- AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WHEN WE MAKE IT HARD
FOR WOMEN TO RETURN TO WORK
AFTER GIVING BIRTH -- DIED IT
SETS THEM BACK ON WE LOOK AT
DISPARITIES IN PAY AND ALL THE
INEQUITIES GENDER INEQUITIES IN
THE WORKPLACE.
PART OF THAT IS THAT WE MAKE IT
HARD FOR WOMEN.
AND MOTHERS TO RETURN TO WORK
AND IT HAS A PERMANENT IMPACT
AND SO THIS WILL HELP TO REDUCE
THOSE DISPARITIES -- SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO --
AND WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE A
SERAPH ISTER -- MOTHER FROM MILL
VALLEY WHO -- WILL SHARE HER
PERSONAL STORY ROBBIE GONZALEZ I
DOUBT FROM THE CONTINENT
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION -- AND CATHERINE WHICH
IT FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR WE
HEAR AND FOR WITNESSES WHICH IS
B. CAN SUPPORT UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL.
I'M ROBBIE GONZALEZ DOWN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION AND WE'RE CO SPONSOR
THE BILL AND I'M GOING TO GIVE
MY TIME TO SERRA -- MOM CALLED
US ABOUT HER CONCERNS IN HER
WORKPLACE.
CHAIR LOW MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
MY NAME'S THEIR FEES ARE AND
WHAT WORKING. THREE OF OUR IT
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
SO BE AGE.
FIVE AGE. THREE FIFTY NINE
MONTHS.
I LIVE IN WORK IN MARIN COUNTY.
DIDN'T ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
SUPPORT FOR SB.
ONE FOUR TWO HOUSTON CONDITION.
AND TO SHARE MY STORY ABOUT HOPE.
OR CRITICAL.
ACTING.
WOMEN IN EATING LIKE THIESSEN AT
WORK. FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS
AFTER OF THIS BETH WAS BORN AND
RETURN TO WORK MY EMPLOYER HAD.
A DESIGNATED ROOM WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS A SIGN THAT THEY
WOULD PROVIDE ADVOCATES SUPPORT
TO NURSING MOMS.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THIS SPACES AND CONVENIENT IT
WAS A FOUR MINUTE WALK FROM MY
WORKS WORK SPACE WHICH I HAD TO
DO THREE TIMES A DAY WHICH WAS
LIKE A TOTAL OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE MINUTES.
WHICH I COULD HAVE SPENT%
DEDICATED TO WORKING WHICH I
WASN'T ABLE TO SEE YOU.
AND MANY TIMES WHEN I WALKED
THERE TO USE IT WAS OCCUPIED.
AND I HAD TO WAIT.
IN THE FIRST TIME I WANT TO USE
IT WITH HIM AND CLEAN.
THEY WERE DEAD ANTS EVERYWHERE
IN THE TRAPS AND THERE'S TRASH
IN THE ROOM.
NO TRASH RECEPTACLES IT'S TRASH
ON FOR I WAS PANICKED BECAUSE MY
HUSBAND AND I BOTH ONE AND FOR
ME TO CONTINUE BREASTFEEDING --
SPIT AFTER I RETURNED TO WORK.
IT'S WHAT OUR PEDIATRICIAN
RECOMMENDED IT AND IT WAS THE
BEST AND HEALTHIEST OPTION. FOR
HER AND WOULD GIVE HER THE BEST
START IN HER LIFE AND THE
BRIGHTEST FUTURE.
DESPITE MY EFFORTS WITH
EDUCATING MY EMPLOYER AND
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION BEST
PRACTICES.
AND WITHOUT HAVING HELP FROM A
THIRD PARTY OR ANY SPECIFIC LAWS
MARK QUEST FOR BETTER SUPPORT
WHAT'S NEXT.
ALMOST EVERY DAY I HAD TO WAIT.
TO SOMETIMES SORTS THAT I COULD
MAKE MY NEXT MEETING. THREE SIX
SHORT WEEKS OF BEING BACK MY
MILK SUPPLY WAS DIMINISHED IT
WAS GONE.
IT WAS DEVASTATING WATCHING MY
SUPPLY DECREASE WEEK AFTER WEEK
WITHOUT ANY SUPPORT.
I FELT LIKE MY RIGHT TO BREAST
FEED WAS BEING DENIED AND THAT
THERE WAS NOTHING I COULD DO
ABOUT IT.
AND WHEN MY SUPPLY FIRST BEGAN
TO DECLINE I THOUGHT ABOUT
QUITTING MY JOB.
I FELT LIKE I HAD TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN MY JOB AND BREAST
FEEDING MY DAUGHTER.
I MADE A PROMISE TO MY
DAUGHTER'S WHICH IS WHY I AM
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB.
ONE FOUR TWO SO THAT WHEN
ELIZABETH MARY AND SELL WE ARE
GROWN UP.
AND JOIN THE WORKPLACE.
THERE WILL BE FALLS IN PLACE. TO
SUPPORT THEM AND THEY WILL ABLE
BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY PROVIDE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN WELL ALSO
FOLLOWING THEIR CAREER GOALS AND
ASPIRATIONS.
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TO CREATE A MORE MODERN
WORKPLACE TO SUPPORT OUR MODERN
WORK FORCE AND ALL THE WOMEN
WORKING IN IT.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SP.
ONE FOUR TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMPELLING TESTIMONY OF THIS
STILL NO COMPLETE THE ALLOTTED
TIME FOR THE THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY ANY ADDITIONAL.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
A STATE THEIR NAME INFORMATION
AND SUPPORT.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE.
SERRA TIAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WITH ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OCCUR GOING ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
I WAS WORKING OUT A SEA OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ERIKA DORSEY WITH FORTUNE
FAMILIES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONG CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
CAN LÏNG ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SIX
NINE NOW CALLED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE TABLE HERE.
AND AGAIN THAT NO MORE THAN
THREE MINUTES OF TESTIMONY INS
IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BECOME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE'RE RESPECTFULLY POSTED
THIS BILL -- WE SUPPORT
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION IN THE
OVERALL GOALS BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL.
WE WORKED WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN LAST YEAR ON HER AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH IS
SIGNED INTO LAW.
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY BECAUSE
I THINK THE AUTHOR SAID CURRENT
LAWS A RESTROOM.
IN THE LAW LAST YEAR SAID THE
LACTATION SPACE HAS TO BE OTHER
THAN A BATHROOM SO IT'S NOT
ALLOWED TO BE THE RESTROOM -- WE
TESTIFIED IN LABOR COMMITTEE
LAST WEEK ABOUT SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL LOCATED IN THE LABOR
CODE AND THE DUPLICATION.
AND POTENTIAL LITIGATION THAT
THOSE -- PROVISIONS COULD CREATE --
ALL LIMIT MY TESTIMONY TODAY TO
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
REQUIREMENTS -- WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE NEW BUILDING STANDARDS
REQUIREMENTS BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
ORDINANCE WOULD RESULT IN
BETWEEN THIRTY AND A HUNDRED AND
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN COSTS
TO BUSINESSES.
AND WHILE THE BILL ELIMINATED
THE SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS IT
SAYS THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
ORDINANCE IS THE STARTING POINT
AND SO WE THINK THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME.
I JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED A SIMILAR
BILL LAST YEAR SB NINE THIRTY
SEVEN NOT BILL DID NOT CONTAIN
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
REQUIREMENTS.
WE'VE ALSO DOES -- PROVISION BE
DELETED FROM THIS BILL BUT FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE POST THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE A VERY TECHNICAL ISSUE
WITH THIS BILL AND THAT IS THE
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENT.
YOU HEARD TESTIMONY TODAY FROM
THE AUTHOR AND FROM THE SPONSORS
THAT THIS BILL ONLY REQUIRES A
TABLE A CHAIR -- A POLICY AND A
PLACE FOR THIS TO HAPPEN NONE OF
THOSE ARE BUILDING CODES.
THERE IS NOTHING FOR THE
BUILDING CODE TO HAPPEN HERE --
WE SUPPORTED THE LACTATION
POLICY IN SAN FRANCISCO WE
HELPED WRITE THAT.
ARE BONUS SAN FRANCISCO GROUP
THERE'S NO BUILDING CODES AND
THAT.
ALL OF THAT IS DEALT WITH IN
SECTION THREE OF THIS BILL IT'S
ALL IN EMPLOYER ACCOMMODATION
IT'S ALL A SERVICE PROVIDED TO
AN EMPLOYER.
THERE'S NO ACTUAL BUILDING CODE
SECTION TO THIS THAT NEEDS TO BE
IN THERE AT A MINIMUM WE WOULD
JUST ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL.
AND JUST CHANGE THE SHALL IN
THAT SECTION TO A MAY AND THAT
WOULD RESULT FOR ISSUES ON THE
BUILDING CODE.
AT WE WE DO WANT TO CALLS
AUTHORS BEEN VERY VERY --
FORTHCOMING WITH US AND HAS
ACTUALLY ADDRESS MANY OF OUR
BUILDING CODE ISSUE SO WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT BUT THAT ONE
LITTLE CHANGE IN SECTION -- ONE
WOULD WOULD RESOLVE OUR ISSUES
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ACTUAL
BUILDING CODES THAT NEED TO BE
WRITTEN TO PROVIDE SOMEONE A
TABLE A CHAIR AND A PRIVATE
CLEAN ROOM THOSE ARE BUILDING
CODES BUILDING BECAUSE A VERY
TECHNICAL.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE ONE ISSUE
RELATED TO MANUFACTURING AND
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION.
SO WE WERE PART OF THE GROUP WHO
NEGOTIATED THE LANGUAGE THAT
EXISTS TO CURRENTLY IN LAW IN
LABOR CO TEN THIRTY ONE RELATED
TO THE HARDSHIP EXEMPTION TO
GIVE FLEXIBILITY TO
MANUFACTURERS.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
INDICATOR FOR WHETHER OR NOT YOU
HAVE A HARDSHIP IS AND HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES THAT YOU HAVE IS
ACTUALLY RELATED TO THE
CONSTRAINTS OF YOUR WORKPLACE.
SO IF YOU HAVE AN INDUSTRIAL
FACILITY MANY OF THESE ARE OPEN
CONCEPT WORK ENVIRONMENTS THE
ONLY PLACE THAT HAS AN ENCLOSED
PLACE THAT WILL PROVIDE THIS IS
THE SAFETY THE PRIVACY -- AND
THE LIMITATION TO EXPOSURE TO
FRANKLY THE BY PRODUCT OF THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS IS IN
UNFORTUNATELY THE RESTROOM BUT
THAT IS THE CONSTRAINTS OF THE
FACILITY SO WE DON'T FEEL BAD
WHETHER IT'S FIFTY PEOPLE OR
FIFTY TWO EMPLOYEES THAT ARE AT
THAT FACILITY.
MAN FACTORS NEED FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT THEY CAN COMPLY WITH THIS
LAW WHEN THEY HAVE NO ABILITY TO
HAVE A PERMANENT STRUCTURE AND
CAN'T PLACE A TEMPORARY
STRUCTURE THERE EITHER BECAUSE
TO DO SO WHEN YOU HAVE.
STATIONARY OR MOBILE INDUSTRIAL
EQUIPMENT THROUGHOUT THAT OPEN
SPACE CONTACT.
ALL UP AND OPEN SPACE A WORK
ENVIRONMENT JUST ISN'T FEASIBLE
FOR THOSE REASONS AS WELL AS THE
REASON STATED PREVIOUSLY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- AND JUST
ONE LAST THING MISTER TRY JUST
WANNA KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE HAD
MEETINGS AND CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE NOW BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WILL BEGIN WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
CENTERS WIENER THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR GOOD WORK THAT YOU DO
AND I JUST WANT TO STATE.
RIGHT FROM THE ONSET THAT I AM
ABSOLUTELY 1100% WITHOUT A
SHADOW OF A DOUBT UNEQUIVOCALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF LACTATION -- THE
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE A SPACE --
FOR LACTATION ACCOMMODATION --
THE TWO CONCERNS WERE BROUGHT UP
BY OPPOSITION I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE ON AS
FAR AS IS THERE A PARTICULAR
REASON WHY IT IS THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES FORCES -- THE FACILITY
ITSELF OR COULD IT BE BOTH OR
DOES IT HAVE TO BE ONE OF THE
OTHER.
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION
[inaudible]
ON MONDAY -- SO WHAT WE PUT INTO
THE BILL OF EXEMPTION THAT WE'RE
IF THIS IS THE FEDERAL --
STANDARD FOR EXAMPLE SO WE CAN.
SORT OF CREATE THIS ON OUR OWN
REGARDING WHAT THE FEDERAL
STANDARD -- SO IT'S YOU CAN
CLAIM A HARDSHIP EXEMPTION IF
YOU'RE FEWER THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES IN WHICH WE ASK YOU
HAVE A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT
MANY BILLS IN THIS BUILDING BUT
THE NEEDS OF SMALL -- SMALLER
BUSINESSES AND SO THAT'S WHY THE
THAT'S WHAT THE HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION AS FOR THAT THE FEWER
THAN.
FIFTY EMPLOYEES -- I UNDERSTAND
WORK WILL OF COURSE CONTINUE TO
TALK TO THE MANUFACTURERS BUT IF
YOU ARE A LARGE BUSINESS WITH
YOU KNOW.
LARGE NUMBER EMPLOYEES YOU.
YOU HAVE I THINK THE ABILITY TO
FIND.
OR CREATE A SPACE SO THAT WOMEN
CAN EXPRESS MILK WITHOUT HAVING
TO SIT ON THE TOILET. TO DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT SO --
YOU KNOW.
THAT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
THAT ARGUMENT IS ABOUT AND WE SO
WE THINK THAT THE FIFTY EMPLOYEE
THRESHOLD.
IS THE RIGHT ONE I LIKE IT'S A
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN
DIALOGUE -- SAY OVER THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BECAUSE THIS IS
OUR SECOND.
ARE RUN -- AT THE BILL WE HAVE
MADE -- HUGE NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS IN RESPONSE TO THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HEARD ABOUT
SOME OF THEM TODAY RIGHT -- WE
MAY MEMBERS LAST YEAR WHICH WE
KEPT IN THE BILL --
OVERWHELMINGLY THIS YEAR
REMEMBER THIS YEAR WILL CONTINUE
TO TALK TO THEM.
AND THEN THE SECOND QUESTION I
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE AND I I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE THAT THERE
CAN BE SOME SPACE MADE I JUST
WANTED HERE SPONSORED.
THE THE OTHER -- ONE DOES COME
FROM SOMEONE WHO IS A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR TO BUILDERS AND IF IT
DOES GET REALLY INTO A VERY
TECHNICAL AREA -- WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT CHANGING BUILDING
CODES AND I LOOKED THROUGH THE
PROVISIONS OF YOUR BILL AND AS I
DID?
I MYSELF WAS REALLY STRETCH TO
FIND AREAS THAT INVOLVED --
BUILDING CODES THAT MOST
EVERYTHING THAT IS LISTED IN THE
BILL CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED VIA THE
LABOR CODE SO THIS IS A QUESTION
I'M TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
BILL TODAY.%
THE CELL AND THAT'S NOT A
QUESTION I JUST IS THERE A
PARTICULAR REASON WHY YOU FEEL
IMPRESSED TO GO VERY VERY
TECHNICAL AND TOUCH SOMETHING IN
THE BUILDING CODE WHEN REALLY
ALL THAT YOU'RE WANTING TO DO
CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED VIA THE
LABOR AGO.
SURE AND I APPRECIATE AND WE'D
AND AS MR HARGROVE AND I THANK
HIM FOR KNOWLEDGE IN THAT WE
CHANGED IT TO INSTEAD OF THE
BILL TRYING TO DICTATE WHAT THE
BUILDING CODE WOULD BE.
JUST ASKING THE THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO COME UP
WITH THAT -- THE RIGHT -- CODE
AND I YOU KNOW I THINK YOU SORT
OF WHAT ONE OF THE OBJECTIONS TO
THIS BILL IS WE HAVE OUR
PHYSICAL SPACE IT IS WHAT IT IS.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE CHALLENGING
FOR US TO CHANGE IT.
RIGHT BECAUSE WE HAVE ERROR FOR
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE EXISTING
SPACE AND YOUR AND AND THAT'S
WHY WE MADE THE BILL FOR THOSE
EXISTING SPACE IS VERY FLEXIBLE --
IN TERMS OF IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
EVEN BE ITS OWN ROOM IT CAN BE A
TEMPORARY -- KIND OF SHIELD --
BUT IF YOU'RE BUILDING A NEW
BUILDING WHAT I DON'T WANT TO
HAVE IS AND THOSE EMPLOYERS COME
BACK AS A WE BUILT IT BUT
THERE'S NO BUT WE DIDN'T THERE'S
NO SPACE IN HERE FOR ANYONE TO
BE ABLE TO EXPRESS MILK SO.
SORRY AND WE'RE GOING TO CLAIM A
HARDSHIP OR WHATEVER AND SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IS
NOT THIS I DON'T ENVISION THIS
IS BEING SOME SORT OF HYPER
COMPLEX TECHNICAL -- BUILDING
CODE PROVISION THIS IS ABOUT
JUST MAKING SURE THAT AYE AYES
ARE BUILDING THESE NEW
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS.
THAT THERE IS THOUGHT GIVEN TO
WEAR OUR NEW MOTHERS GOING TO
EXPRESS MAIL AND AND AND SO I
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
SIMPLE -- BUT IT'S TRYING TO
AVOID WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
SOME KERN EMPLOYERS LIKE
MANUFACTURERS SAYING WELL WE
DON'T HAVE THAT'S BEING SOMEONE
THAT'S IN DETERMINING
INSPECTIONS AND PULL OUT PERMITS
TO DO REMODELS AND DIFFERENT
THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND BRINGING THINGS UP TO A
CURRENT CODE IN A BUILDING THAT
IS AGE.
I I SHARE YOUR SENTIMENTS THAT I
HOPE THE COMMISSION FINDS IT TO
BE AS SIMPLE AS YOU'RE
EXPRESSING -- MY DOUBTS OF THEIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMILAR
GRAYSON ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR WIENER TO
RECYCLE DISTRICT WEST RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AGAIN
WANTED THANK -- YOUR AND
TENACITY. FOR YET AGAIN COMING
BEFORE US TO PRESENT ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE ALSO AB
WITNESS THAT THIS ENJOYED OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
AND HOPE YOU ALSO SEE THAT AS
WELL AND WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES MISSION.
TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMPELLING TESTIMONY.
THE SERVER IS JUST I'D ONE THING
THAT I NEGLECTED TO MENTION I
WAS REFERENCE MADE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOANS BILL -- FROM LAST
YEAR THIS IS BUILDING ON THAT
BILL SOME ANIMAL KNOWN AS CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL I WAS A CO
AUTHOR OF HER BILL LAST YEAR.
THERE'S NO CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE KNOW THIS
DOES ENJOY A DEEP PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WILL IT END CHANGE THE MOTION.
QUESTION IS A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB ONE FORTY TO MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
WELL I BROKE.
WE'RE NOT VOTING ARAMBULA REBEL
I BLOOM.
MY CHEN.
I'M NOT GOING TO JAIL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG?
PHONE NUMBER IN.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAY AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN?
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NO TING.
TING AYE. TWELVE TO ONE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS THAT'S INCLUDES ALL OF
THE PRESENTATIONS OF THE BILLS
WILL LEAVE -- THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL TEN MINUTES BUT WE'LL
GO THROUGH THE WALL.
ONCE MORE SO THAT WILL BEGIN IN
FIVE ORDER WHICH IS FILE ITEM.
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS JUST HEARD
BUT THEN THAT WILL THEN MOVE ON
TO CONSENT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB THREE
NINETY ONE MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS BRO.
BRO I CHILL [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING TING AYE
[inaudible] SEVENTEEN VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT.
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH
IS SB FOUR SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER.
SB FOR SEVENTY FIVE MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS BRO. FOR
AYE CHILL [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE. SIXTEEN VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM THEN
NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE
BY CENTER CARILLO.
SB FIVE ANYONE MOTIONS YOU PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
WE'RE NOT VOTING [inaudible]
JILL [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING TING AYE.
THIRTEEN VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT
FINALLY FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
FIVE NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD.
SB FIVE NINETY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
POSSIBLE CREATIONS CHILL
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
TING TING AYE. THIRTEEN VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT.
SB ONE FORTY TWO MOTIONS YOU
PASSES APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE
ABOUT CHANGING FONG FONG NOT
VOTING TO NOW
.
SB ONE FORTY TWO EMERGENCY BASS
AS AN INITIAL PREPARATIONS. TO
TO AYE CUNNINGHAM GIPSON. THIRTY
TWO BILLS OUT.
ON THE COUNTER SB THREE NINETY
ONE MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
PREPARATIONS. TWO FIVE TWO AYE
GIPSON. EIGHTEEN ZERO BILLS OUT.
AS BEFORE SEVENTY FIVE MOTIONS
YOU PASTOR PREPARATIONS CHILL.
TO AYE GIPSON. SEVENTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
SB FIVE ANYONE MOTIONS YOU PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHU
CHU I GIPSON. FOURTEEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
SB FIVE NINETY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS. TO TO I
GIPSON. FOURTEEN TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT